im schnee der antarktis haben münchner
forschen der etwas gefunden das nicht
aus unserem sonnensystem stammt konkret
geht es um das isotop eisen 60 dass
keine natürlichen quellen her auf der
erde hat ist es vielleicht durch eine
supernova auf unseren heimatplaneten
gelangt es ist auf jeden fall
unglaublich spektakulär denn wenn es im
schnee gefunden wurde
dann ist es erst vor ganz ganz kurzer
zeit auf die erde gelangt was ist da
passiert die zum science fiction ihr
jetzt täglich spannendes sein sidos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
schon 2015 nahm die ganze spektakuläres
tor ihren lauf damals hatte das
forschungsteam von der tu münchen und
dem alfred-wegener-institut viel zu tun
nader conan station eine deutsche polar
forschungsstation in der antarktis
sollte eine halbe tonne schnee geschippt
werden natürlich alles für die
wissenschaft insgesamt 25 kisten voll
mit schnee machten sich damals dann auf
eine lange reise zunächst mit dem
flugzeug an die antarktischen küste
dann ging es weiter mit dem schiff nach
kapstadt und dann schlussendlich nach
münchen der schnee wurde dort
geschmolzen und genauer analysiert und
der plan von gunther kinect ging
tatsächlich auf der physiker hatte
darauf spekuliert dass in dem antarktis
schnee ein spektakulärer fund gemacht
werden könnte
denn schon vor 20 jahren gelang dem
wissenschaftler von der tu münchen der
nachweis des isotops eisen 60 in tiefsee
ablagerung schon damals stand die
vermutung im raum dass dieser fund von
eisen 60 in einer mangan küste der
tiefsee auf eine supernova hinweisen
könnte diese habe möglicherweise vor
rund zwei millionen jahren in der nähe
unseres sonnensystems stattgefunden und
auch im reinen schnee der antarktis
marcinek sich gute chancen aus weitere
eisen 60 ablagerungen zu finden anders
als in anderen regionen dieser erde
denn der feine staub des kosmos geht
gewöhnlich in der natur unter das
radioaktive isotop eisen 60 ist genauso
wie fast alle anderen chemischen
elemente die uns bekannt sind eins im
inneren von sternen oder weil
sternenexplosionen entstanden
doch dieses isotop ist sehr selten und
instabil
es hat eine halbwertszeit von 2,62
millionen jahren
das heißt dass sich seine ursprünglich
vorhandene menge alle 2,6 millionen
jahre halbiert kreis also wenn vor 4,6
milliarden jahren als die erde
entstanden ist eisen 60 vorhanden
gewesen sein sollte muss es bis heute
vollständig zerfallen sein gelingt der
nachweis auf der erde ist somit klar
dass es vor nicht allzu langer zeit aus
dem weltraum gekommen sein muss vor
nicht allzu langer zeit das ist
natürlich in astronomische dimensionen
gemeint kinect sollte mit seiner
vermutung was den antarktis schnee
angeht tatsächlich recht behalten
bei der analyse im labor ließen sich in
den proben fünf teilchen des seltenen
eisen 60 isotops nachweise eine premiere
denn bislang konnte dieses isotop noch
niemals in einer schnee probe aufgespürt
werden
eine super spannende und
verantwortungsvolle arbeit die dafür
notwendig war
dazu die wissenschaftlerin silke mersch
die an der chemischen analyse beteiligt
war ich habe vorher mit lehrern filtern
geübt damit bei der endgültigen arbeit
mit der wertvollen probe nichts
schiefgeht außerdem habe ich geschaut
welche elemente in den filtern und
verwendeten chemikalien schon drin sind
denn die späteren messungen waren so
empfindlich dass man damit alles findet
die genaue analyse zeigte dass das
aufgespürte isotop mit sehr großer
sicherheit aus einer supernovaexplosion
stammt weder atomwaffentests noch die
sekundäre einwirkung kosmischer
strahlung kommen nach angabe des
forschungsteams als mögliche quellen in
frage
doch die fachleute wissen sogar noch
mehr denn dadurch dass der schnee aus
der antarktis nicht älter als 20 jahre
ist das ist nichts müssen diese relikte
einer supernova erst vor kurzer zeit auf
die erde nieder gegangen sei die
sternenexplosion wird
höchstwahrscheinlich sogar in unserer
kosmischen nachbarschaft stattgefunden
haben denn sonst wäre der staub aus
eisen 60 stärker verdünnt und somit kaum
noch in nachweisbarer menge auf der erde
aufzuspüren nach ansicht der fachleute
handelt es sich bei der quelle dieser
eisen 60 partikel höchst wahrscheinlich
um eine der interstellaren gaswolken
durch die wir mit unserem sonnensystem
der zeit hindurch fliegen dazu günter
kruschina
eine wolke in unserer direkten er ist
die sogenannte local inter stella cloud
die durch eine supernova entstanden sein
könnte
doch diese vermutung kann erst durch
weitere untersuchungen mit letzter
sicherheit bestätigt werden das
spezielle eisen 60 isotop dürfte dann
nämlich erst in eisschichten der
antarktis auftauchen die jünger sind als
40.000 jahre was die aktuelle
untersuchung aber sehr deutlich macht
auch in unserer kosmischen nachbarschaft
haben explosionen von sternen
stattgefunden
und dies kann somit auch in zukunft
immer wieder geschehen auf funde von
eisen 60 in fossilien und
gesteinsschichten legen übrigens nach
das war etwa 2,6 millionen jahren eine
supernova stattgefunden haben muss und
zwar in nur 150 lichtjahren entfernung
von der erde
das ist quasi nichts möglicherweise ist
sogar unser sonnensystem durch eine nahe
sternenexplosion entstanden
wann sehen wir eine supernova mit bloßem
auge am himmel gute frage anklicken wenn
es wissen wollt anschauen und neugier
zum abonnieren
ich bin auf die antwort wirklich
gespannt bis dann bleibt dran